Hello world.
It's a Raj and AI in marketing.
That's the copic for today's video.
I want to start off this video with a demo and what this is is an AI writer.
What it does is it takes in as input a keyword.
In my case,
I'll say it's going to be wine.
Okay,
so I want to write an article about red wine and I'm going to send it to my
email address.
It's going to use an AI to then generate an article based on that.
It might take a few minutes,
it might take a few hours,
but luckily I already have the outputs right here for us.
What it does is it cause it's going to generate text based on that keyword and
it's gonna use its sources are going to be the internet,
so it's going to search the Internet for other related articles on the topic.
It's going to take all that text and compile it into one giant text dataset.
It's going to feed that into its AI model,
which is likely an LSTM neural network.
Don't worry if you don't understand that,
I'll talk about that later in the video.
And then it's going to output an,
an article that we see here is going to be a very compressed article,
low compression.
It can be a medium or a high compression article and they can get pretty good.
Okay.
Pretty damn good.
So good.
In fact that it's very likely that you've already write an article or seen some
kind of data that was created entirely by an AI and you didn't even know it.
Very famous brands from Fox to Yahoo to the Associated Press,
all use AI to generate content.
And that's just one of the ways that AI can be used in both marketing,
advertising and the entire marketing funnel,
the pipeline.
So in this video,
I'm going to talk about ways we can do that.
And at the very end we're going to look at some code for different architectures
that we can use to do this.
Okay,
so let's start off with the ways that AI can be used in marketing,
right?
So one way is through audience targeting,
So if you have some startup,
a company,
a brand,
you have an audience of customers,
right?
And if you have some new product,
you want to target those specific subset of your customers that are going to be
most,
uh,
willing to convert into sales.
You don't want to waste your time,
your energy,
your money,
your resources on customers who won't convert,
right?
And so how do you target those exact customers that would be most likely to
convert?
This is a perfect use case for AI and we'll talk about that in a bit.
The second part is content creation,
right?
If you've already targeted those users that are most likely to convert to sales
for your product,
how are then,
how are you supposed to generate content that would be best suited for them?
The ideal,
the easy way is to get a human to do it.
But could you get an AI to do it?
Is the question.
And the answer of course is yes,
and we'll talk about that as well.
Now,
real time optimization is another strategy using Ai.
Let's say you have some marketing campaign.
Let's say it's an email campaign rights,
and you're constantly sending ads out to your users to see how they feel about
the product and you're getting feedback from them,
whether they like it or not.
How do you optimize that content,
your route in real time so that you're learning from what your users like and
what they don't like.
And this has been happening,
like I said,
for a very,
very long time.
And we're going to learn how in this video,
so some B,
two B marketers were asked,
what are these metrics that indicate successful return on Ai Investment?
And across the board that the number one way with 59% of respondents saying this
was,
that gives them better close rates for sales.
So sales equates to revenue.
And revenue is the lifeblood of any company,
right?
You can't have a company if you don't have revenue,
okay?
So if I didn't have revenue,
I couldn't hire people.
I couldn't make videos for you.
I couldn't live.
I've got revenue,
okay?
So,
and I am using AI to help target my content.
So I myself and admitting that I'm using AI to help target and you know,
make sure my content is as,
as targeted as possible.
And they say in the end,
if you have some product that you're selling,
it's going to then help close the rates for sales,
right?
For me,
for me,
that was my decentralized applications course.
That was my only paid offering up to this point.
And I targeted it very well and it resulted in some good sales,
which is gonna help me grow the business later on.
So Ai can be used for that as well.
So let's talk about some startups in the space that are helping to move this
field forward,
right?
So happier is one example.
This is a Taiwan based company and what they do is they predict what audience
members are likely to do next,
right?
So if you have some products or some ecommerce websites and you're selling shoes
and you're selling all sorts of clothing,
let's say if a customer buys shoes,
then it is likely that the customer won't buy another pair of shoes.
But it is likely that they'll buy a pair of socks.
The compliment those shoes,
how can you predict what the customer is going to do next?
And what they do is they provide AI as a service to companies to allow them to
predict what customers are going to do next.
Another example is drawbridge,
right?
So users switch devices all the time,
So they can be on mobile,
that can be on desktop,
that can be on a ps four and ideally we can,
we can target the type of content to the specific device that they're on at the
time.
And so that's what drawbridge does.
It predicts what times that a user is going to be on a specific platform and
then it allows a brand to create content based on that platform.
Another example is inside sales.com right?
So if you have a lot of perspective sales,
you can just target all of them because you're going to be wasting time and
energy and money on targeting this giant segment of users.
When it turns out that the,
the customers that are most likely to convert are probably only 20% and that's
what inside sales does,
is it helps you find that 20% of your customer base that are going to be the
most likely to convert to the sales for your product that you're pushing.
And there's one more I want to talk about.
It's called Persado.
What they do is they will help you create content.
Hey,
we'll help you find the phrases and the words that's going to drive the greatest
action for your audience to convert into sales.
So you could say,
you know,
a text message in this way,
but if you say it in this way,
you reworded a little bit,
it's going to increase sales by this much.
And this is something that we humans try to do.
We use our intuition,
right?
So you know don draper from mad men,
he comes into the boardroom,
he's like,
this is going to work.
And then it works and it's beautiful.
That's not how it works anymore.
If you don't have a database decision,
what are you doing?
Right?
So really good marketers and really good,
um,
you know,
salespeople and advertiser,
not salespeople.
Advertisers tells people as well,
but not in this case,
use AI to make decisions,
okay?
It's not just about intuition alone.
You've got to use it.
You've got to base your decision on the data.
If you don't got the data,
you don't got anything,
right?
So Shit.
So anyway,
he's dope.
Let's start with audience targeting,
right?
So how do we target some segment of the audience that is going to be most likely
to convert for a given ad and then focus all of our time and energy on that
segments.
So we could think about this as a recommender system problem,
right?
So a bunch of sites use recommender systems,
Amazon,
Netflix,
you know,
everybody uses it these days.
And one very common way to build a recommender systems,
it's a huge matrix factorization,
okay?
So here's how it works.
If you have some product,
and in this case we're talking about marketing.
So our product is going to be a,
an ad,
right?
So you have a bunch of ads you've tried out and the users rated all of those ads
on a scale of one to 10 and what this turns out is you have a giant matrix of
users and ads and their ratings for all of those ads.
So it turns out that those users aren't going to rate all of those ads.
They're only going to rate some of them.
So what we do for Matrix factorization is we decompose this giant matrix into
two different matrices.
One is going to be how a user's rates certain features of an ad.
The other is going to be how certain features are rated by users for a specific,
um,
ad.
So two different matrices.
The process of decomposing this matrix into a two different feature matrix sees
is a type of machine learning using neural networks or SPD is.
But I've talked about that before.
If you search Saroj recommender system on youtube,
you'll find a bunch of videos there.
But I want to give you a high level explanation here.
Once we've decomposed that giant matrix into these two smaller matress seats,
we then use the dot product to combine them again in such a way that all of
those blank spaces are filled,
right?
So what we're trying to do is we're trying to find those blank spaces.
If a user has rated a certain ad this way and another ad this way,
how would they rate this ad?
And so this is a prediction.
This is what the AI is doing using Matrix factorization,
popular library to do this has been light FM.
I made a video on that before where it takes a generates user and item
representations by functioning has factorization machines and learning the
linear embeddings for each feature.
It then takes a dot products of each of these two representation vector and gets
a score.
But with deep neural networks,
we can improve on this by creating more meaningful representations.
Right?
Deep neural networks outperformed all other machine learning models when it
comes to learning,
uh,
features.
Okay?
So when it comes to learning features,
deep neural net blow everything else out of the water.
If we have enough data and computing power and so tense or rec is a library that
has a lot of developer activity and highly recommended built on top of
tensorflow that does this.
It allows us to use tensor flow to build deep neural networks for recommendation
engines.
This can be to recommend the optimal ads for your users to recommend products to
recommend whatever it is.
Now,
ideally,
if you're a brand,
if you're a company,
you've got some data set that shows how users feel about certain ads you've done
in the past and based on that you can create new ads that a certain user would
be likely to convert on.
So you have to make sure you have that data.
If you don't have that data,
you're a startup,
you want to build a service for brands and just Google datasets for data's had
ad campaign and then test it out from there.
But the idea is that going beyond Matrix factorization,
we can build neural networks to do this,
right?
And so the process is very similar in that we are learning to matrices and then
we're performing a dot product between those two matrices to create predicted
scores for a given user.
And then we just read off of that Matrix to predict what a certain user would
score a particular ad.
And then if we have some threshold,
like if a user scores would score above an eight out of 10 for this ad,
then deploy this ad to them if it's under that then deployed this ad to them.
Okay.
So it's Kinda like that.
So there are four steps in this process.
The first one,
it's a transform our input data into feature tensors for easy embedding,
right?
We have some input data that's a giant matrix and then we use pandas say to then
convert that into a data frame object.
And once we do that,
we convert them to feature tensors using an algorithm like word two Vec,
which we could use in one line of code or several other ones.
And then once we have that,
we transform the user item feature tensors into future item representations.
We transformed that pair into a prediction and then transform that prediction
and truth value into a loss value for loss function.
Minimize that using gradient descent until we have reached a minimum minimal
loss function value.
And then we can use that model to predict what a certain user would like.
So here is a very simple programmatic example of us using tensor rec to
recommend users.
A specific type of data.
This could be ads,
it could be anything,
right?
So we build a model in a single line,
that's all we imported.
We generate some dummy data,
we fit the [inaudible] model on that data.
We predict,
uh,
what the scores would be would be based on the given data.
And then we use a percentage recall as a evaluation metric to see how good it's
doing on testing datasets.
That's it tend to wreck,
check it out.
Now,
once we have targeted a specific subset of our users that we know exactly,
we've automated that part of the pipeline.
Now we can use humans to create content that is perfectly well suited for them.
Or we could automate the entire pipeline where it's not just us targeting the
users using AI will generate content for those users using Ai.
So the entire process is automated,
right?
So this video is content.
This video could be automated.
I who knows if I'm real or not,
right?
You have no idea unless you met me in real life.
But even then,
who knows?
Maybe I was a Hologram.
Anyway,
content creation,
right?
So LSTM networks are the way to do this for text.
Okay?
So if you search LSTM networks,
Raj,
you find a great video on me explaining how they work in depth,
but I'll give you a high level overview right now.
So recurrent networks are really good at predicting sequences of,
of texts,
right?
So normal feedforward networks,
Normal feedforward networks are not about predicting sequences.
There are about predicting what an output would be for a given input.
It learns the mapping.
But when it comes to a sequence,
what happened before matters to what happens now?
What,
what the word that you had previously,
like hi,
like recording videos about Ai.
Because I love,
you know,
maybe it's tensorflow,
but predict what that word is.
You got to know about the word Ai.
You've got to know about the word video.
You can just know,
you know,
use the previous word.
You've got to use the whole sequence,
right?
So what we're current networks do is at every time step,
it's not just the next data point that's fed into the network.
It's also the previous hidden layer that's learned over time.
It's fed into the time step.
And so at every time step,
not just a new data point,
but the previous hidden layer that was learned is fed into the network.
So it's learning not just the next data point,
but it's learning based on what I already learned before,
if that makes sense.
And that's why it's called a recurrent network because there is this recurrence
or feedback loop that's happening.
And what's,
there's a problem though in that for recurrent networks,
if the sequence is uh,
too long,
then there's going to be a problem called the vanishing gradient problem.
So during optimization backpropagation and we use the gradient,
which is the difference between the real output into predicted output.
We use the gradient to then update all of those layers beforehand.
But what happens in recording networks is that gradient gets smaller and smaller
and smaller.
The further back we go in the network.
And so how do we preserve that gradient?
So all the layers are updated accordingly.
While we need to trap that gradient somehow into what are called long short term
memory cells,
cells that consists of gates values and these trap the gradients in such a way
at the vanishing gradient goes away.
And this allows a network to remember a very,
very,
very long term sequences of data,
like an entire essay,
right?
So they let us then write an entire essay or article.
And so you might be thinking,
how do I build this very complex thing?
And the answer is carrots.
Carrots is a machine learning library built on top of tensorflow and let you
build very complex,
deep neural networks in just a few lines of code.
And Ai marketers can use this to automatically generate content best suited for
a particular subset of their audience.
So the idea is that if you have images or video,
then you want to use generative adversarial networks to generate content.
If you want to generate audio,
you use wave nets and if you want to use,
if you want to generate text,
you use LSTM recurrent networks like I'm talking about here.
And remember I have videos for all of these models is search my name and the
model.
So here's a very simple example of us using care os in under a hundred lines of
code that generates an essay in the style of niche.
So the text is niches writing and then what it does is it takes that input data,
it's formats that data,
it feeds it into a model built in os where every line of code corresponds to a
single layer and the network.
So it's very readable code and it's only three layers long.
We optimize it using rms prop,
which is a type of gradient descent search.
Which activation function should I use Saroj on youtube to find a great video on
all the differences between all of the different activation functions out there.
You know,
I also have a video in which optimization function should you use as well.
But anyway,
once we do that,
we minimize it using a loss function.
And that's it.
And then what it's gonna do is it's going to predict every word,
uh,
that,
that Nietzsche would have said based on what it's learned in the past.
And so we can use this for the entire pipeline,
whether we're targeting users and then once we've targeted them generating
content for them,
and we can do this for the entire marketing pipeline.
There's any,
there's a huge,
huge space for startups to come into this space and create services for big
brands,
for consumers to help them optimize,
to save time,
to save money,
to save resources using the latest technologies.
And look,
even though I said that there are some startups out there that do this
currently,
there's a giant,
massive opportunity for new players in this space and there's a huge need for it
as well.
So I hope you found this video useful.
Please subscribe for more programming videos,
and for now,
I've got to be an AI,
so thanks for watching.